un à un les corps sont emportés pas un
jour sans que le coran navires us ne
fassent de nouvelles victimes sur le sol
américain
les dépouilles sont entreposés dans des
camions frigorifiques transformé en
morgue
ces nouveaux décès s'ajoute à la longue
liste de morts recensés aux états unis
1200 rien que ces dernières 24 heures
près de 10000 depuis le début de
l'épidémie
c'est trois fois plus de victimes que
les attaques du 11 septembre
une comparaison historique qui sonne
juste pour donald trump qui met en garde
le peuple américain
les etats unis s'apprêtent à vivre des
semaines terribles avec je pense que
nous savons tous que nous devons
atteindre un certain pic qui va être
terrible en termes de morts mais c'est
aussi un pic où les choses ont commencé
à changer
nous approchons très près de ce niveau
en ce moment et durant la prochaine
semaine et demie peut-être même les deux
prochaines semaines
je pense que cela va être très difficile
en même temps ces prochaines semaines
sont cruciales
le temps est crucial et j'espère que
nous allons surmonter cela car c'est une
chose terrible pour le monde entier pour
réduire le nombre de victimes
donald trump a appelé l'armée en renfort
3000 militaires et professionnels de
santé comme en cent six à être déployé
dans les états les plus touchés par le
cos vite 19 comme ici à new york
épicentre de l'épidémie une dès qu'apple
déplore à elle seule plus de 600 morts
chaque jour
face au manque de personnels de santé à
la pénurie en équipements vitaux comme
des respirateurs le maire de la ville
bill de blasio s'inquiète du nombre des
victimes sans cesse croissant agathe des
arts
j'ai dit aux gens toute la vérité sur ce
que nous avons vu toute la semaine
dernière et cette semaine jusqu'à ce
dimanche 5 avril
en résumé comme nous l'avons dit plus
tôt dans la soirée c'est qu'il y a moyen
de récupérer des équipements cruciaux
comme les respirateurs
pour les respirateurs je me répète mais
quand les gens en ont besoin quand le
médecin on a besoin pour un patient il
n'y a pas une minute à perdre il les
faut dès lors qu'une vie est en jeu
c'est pourquoi jusqu'à présent nous
sommes si précis pour prévoir le stade
où la ville viendra à manquer d'ici là
new york comme le reste du pays retient
son souffle
[Musique]